[Musica]
ogni civiltà ha prodotto le sue rovine
mi domando la nostra riuscirà a produrre
o lascerà solo macerie
se lo tennero luoghi come questo il
famoso antropologo marc augé sosteneva
che le macerie accumulate della storia
recente e le rovine dato dal passato non
si assomigliano c'è differenza tra il
tempo storico della distruzione
che rivela la follia della storia e
tutti noi tutti noi questi giorni siamo
testimoni di la tragedia proprio nel
cuore dell'europa e il tempo puro quello
delle rovine noi immaginiamo il nostro
passato attraverso
la scoperta e la conoscenza dei suoi
frammenti e le rovine private dai
profumi dalle relazioni dalle tensioni
dagli scambi tra i popoli che le hanno
abitate prodotte sono monumenti di un
mondo senza tempo sono
specchi di una società sulle quali si
fonda il nostro presente per la storia
del pensiero occidentale
l'estetica delle rovine è un alimento
cruciale perché c'è una contesa tra
natura e cultura una sospensione tra
distruzione e ricostruzione
ed è proprio in questa ambivalenza che
troviamo una spinta verso la modernità
verso noi che li ammiriamo in questa
fase che chiamiamo antropocene cioè la
nostra quella in cui è l'uomo che ha
modellato e modella l'ambiente intorno a
sé disegnare in cui viviamo sono lo
sfruttamento intensivo delle risorse
naturali
una gli ecosistemi minacciati da una
massiccia di stilizzazione
cataclismi naturali e mutazioni
climatiche
viviamo in un tempo accelerato in cui
non c'è spazio per la contemplazione e i
cicli di produzione consumo e crisi
rinascita sono sempre più frenetiche
tutto questo potrebbe portare a un mondo
senza rovine
in cui il tempo sarà azzerato e non ci
sarà più storia ma quando le rovine
hanno cominciato ad essere
percepite in modo completamente nuovo
le vestigia classiche presenti nelle
opere del medioevo e nella pittura del
rinascimento
diventano per i pittori del barocco e
del settecento i principali soggetti di
paesaggi bucolici in cui architetture
maestose reali dimensioni
dominano le figure al loro interno
la sensibilità romantica
uso una forte componente malinconica
alla contemplazione di natura e i ruderi
una poetica nostalgia dell'armonia
perduta in questa prospettiva le rovine
non sono più concepite come ciò che è
sopravvissuto di un'opera originaria ma
al contrario sono percepite come
qualcosa di autonomo come risultato del
trascorrere del tempo
la rovina non è più riconosciuta come un
frammento architettonico ma come
sopravvivenza all'oblio e quindi anche
come specchio della fragilità umana
poi questa visione verrà demolita e
contestata nella breve stagione delle
avanguardie artistiche come il futurismo
in cui il mito della velocità della
macchina e della tecnologia aprirono le
porte al novecento ma veniamo alle
rovine moderne a tutta quella geografia
invisibile intorno a noi di edifici e
paesi abbandonati tutti noi passiamo
ogni giorno con indifferenza davanti a
luoghi che nascondono ancora tanta
bellezza e veri e propri tesori
e la documentazione è fondamentale ed è
proprio la storia che raccontano questi
posti ciò che mi muove molti si
domandano come faccio a trovarli beh li
trovo con ricerca ossessiva e sul web e
con l'aiuto di alcuni contatti fidati
sparsi per l'europa poi capita di
imbattermi raramente in un posto
interessante mentre sono in viaggio in
quel caso la soddisfazione per la
scoperta è doppia io la chiamo con me è
la mia serie di pit in pratica il
fotografo da diversi anni sono sempre
stato interessato alla loro epifania
alla loro europea e la loro scomparsa
definitiva infatti il titolo del mio
progetto e anche del mio libro è meno
meno lo jia della fine
viaggio per il mondo cercando di
riscoprire la gloria passata di luoghi
dimenticati e gli oggetti fatiscenti e
le stanze desuete presenti nel mio
lavoro rivestono la stessa funzione che
ricopre il marcel proust della madre
cioè quella di evocare il ricordo di un
età felice non sono interessato al
semplice abbandono bensì al
nel tempo alle varie stratificazioni che
definiscono la decadenza di un ambiente
e per farvi capire meglio come è
cambiato il mio senso estetico
vorrei citare un poema di victor hugo in
cui si scagliò contro l'inespressività
dei monumenti troppo nuovi opponendo ad
essi il fascino delle rovine anche io
immagino come edificio perfetto quello a
cui il tempo ha portato il suo tocco
finale non so per quale motivo ma quando
entro in un luogo in rovina
abbasso il tono della voce
cerco di camminare fragile per camminare
frase le per non provocare rumori
resta in ascolto mi muovo come se mi
trovassi all'interno di un negozio di
cose preziose cercando di non toccare
più del dovuto entro nelle chiese visito
le case calpesto il terreno delle
fabbriche dismesse e nel farlo mi
convinco che tutto quel vuoto abbia a
che fare con me con la mia vita con le
mie visioni con le mie paure più
profonde con le mie origini è come se mi
trovassi davanti e scoprirsi i miei
antenati e questo mi pone una condizione
di turbamento e frigidità assoluta pensa
a questi posti come a ci vuole da
sbucciare
arrivare al cuore alla polpa vorrei
dedicare un canto collettivo una
preghiera rituale per
giocare gli spiriti di questi luoghi
ideare il giorno della città abbandonata
mi racconta nella storia come
nell'antologia in cui edgar lee masters
narrava le storie dei morti di spoon
river potrebbe avere un significato
profondo un
sciamanico una riflessione popolare su
chi eravamo su chi non siamo più e sulla
natura e potremmo partire proprio da
questi posti per ritrovare una relazione
intima con la natura approfondire il
concetto di tempo dilatato che possa
rallentare fino a quasi a fermarsi e
godere della meravigliosa immagine del
silenzio
a questo proposito vorrei citare la
teoria
del terzo paesaggio del paesaggista
francese gilles clément come possiamo
definire il terzo paesaggio
beh sono tutti quegli spazi vuoti
marginali privi di esseri umani a
occuparli
privi di funzioni meravigliosamente
inutili che non sono sottoposti a nessun
potere però non dobbiamo pensare a come
salvarli o riabilitarli non proviamo
nostalgia per quello che erano dovremmo
accettare lo spazio vuoto come
accettiamo il nostro inconscio
questi posti si trovano ai bordi ultimi
era un posto di un mondo ai confini di
qualcosa alle periferie ma dentro i
perimetri qualche anno fa a napoli a
castel dell'ovo ho intitolato una mia
mostra hic sunt draconis qui sono i
draghi l'altra espressione gemella e hic
sunt leones i leoni e questa espressione
latina era associata alle carte
geografiche antiche per indicare le zone
ancora inesplorate ecco io ho intitolato
la mostra in questo modo per alzare il
velo su tutti quei posti del nostro
paese che sono tornati ad essere fuori
dalle mappe
l'italia è cambiata sono cambiate
soprattutto le relazioni
interni esterni centro periferia
montagna pianura ed è stato un
cambiamento non governato di cui ci
siamo accorti troppo tardi
il territorio montano è diventato
improduttivo e quindi sacrificabile i
segnali sono stati piccoli ma è
inequivocabili il piccolo edificio
postale che chiude il bar che ingloba
l'edicola e poi diventa piccolo
supermercato
giovani sono andati alla storia della
grande città molti altri all'estero e
dopo anni di illusioni di svuotamento di
abbandono forse è arrivato il momento di
riposizionarsi di ritrovare un centro di
cambiare il paradigma e per per farlo
dovremo fare della periferia
un'alternativa
dovremmo
considerare il nostro paese e non
soffermarsi alla superficie dovremmo
considerarlo come un corpo quindi non
fermarsi alla porzione di pelle visibile
a tutti al tronco alle braccia al viso
ma analizzare anche gli organi che non
si vedono
fegato intestino cuore cervello potrebbe
essere una meravigliosa avventura
riconsiderare la rovina
come un elemento che ci appartiene
fare conti con le macerie come fare
conti con le nostre ferite
i nostri fallimenti
sovrapporre la topografia del paesaggio
continuamente alla nostra topografia
interiore non rimuovere ma ascoltare
l'abbandono prendersene cura acquisirlo
in quanto facente parte di noi della
nostra storia e del nostro futuro ma per
farlo dovremo imporci di malinconia e di
stupore che ne pronunceremo ancora il
nome
allora le rovine rimarranno ancora in
piedi ma se per qualche motivo
dimenticheremo una frazione una località
se nella fretta o per superficialità o
leggerezza dimenticheremo il nome di una
città fantasma
allora crollerà tutto di nuovo
rotoleranno a valle gli ultimi sassi i
muri verranno giù
e le porte usciranno dai cardini che le
sostenevano e io credo che tutto questo
sarebbe imperdonabile quello che
fotografo si trasforma continuamente
il tempo divoratore o scelte umane
scellerate spesso sentenza no la
scomparsa definitiva di questi luoghi
quindi le mie foto fanno parte di un
vero e proprio catalogo sentimentale che
mi riportano sempre alle sensazioni
provate al momento dello scatto che
rimane unico e tutto questo mi dona
veramente qualcosa di prezioso il senso
di meraviglia di quando avevo 8 anni
grazie
[Musica]